the end of the queue borg history
rewritten picard season 2 left plenty
unanswered
one of the most anticipated star trek
returns since the next generation crew
came back is actor john de lancie who
reprised the role of the enigmatic and
omnipotent trickster q and when he
arrived we knew right away he wasn't the
same more than just older hugh seemed
darker more sinister and with a bitter
edge once again q put picard through a
personal test getting him to fix a
change in time and learn a lesson about
himself along the way while this
mirrored episodes like tapestry and all
good things something was different this
time around this time q was dying
according to q he was slowly losing his
powers and nearing the end of his
existence something he didn't think
possible in the season finale farewell q
says he's finally ready to cease being
he uses the last ounce of his power to
send picard and his crew home and bring
elnor back to life but is this really
the end of q or does death among the q
mark an end to the entire q continuum in
star trek discovery starfleet claims
that they haven't had an encounter with
the continuum in 600 years leaving a gap
that could still be filled
in a shocking last minute twist trekkies
got the answers to two long unresolved
questions when wesley crusher made a
surprise appearance showing that he was
no longer in starfleet and was now a
traveler just like the enigmatic alien
we met on the next generation wesley
confirmed that he and others like him
employ the likes of talon and the
original series gary seven as
supervisors who monitor historical
events and ensure that the timeline
plays out as it should you interfere
with me with what i have to do down
there
and you'll change history
when wesley arrives he's in 2024 he
visits adam sung's daughter corey who he
recruits to join him with her father
disgraced and her life a lie corey takes
wesley up on the offer and the two beam
away though one might suspect that
wesley is enlisting her to be a traveler
it seems more likely that corey was
recruited to be the next supervisor
could corey be assigned a new subject to
monitor in 2024 or some other time
period could we see wesley and corey
return in the kind of spin-off that gary
7 was created for a show about a time
traveling agent watching over important
historical events producer alex kurtzman
has teased some upcoming mystery
projects in the star trek universe and
this is one that definitely seems like a
possibility cristobal chris rios was
introduced as a rogue captain in the
first season of picard he left starfleet
under shadowy circumstances following a
scandal and cover-up and went on to
become an independent operator
captaining the starship la sirena at the
end of the first season he returned to
starfleet now commander of the uss
stargazer captain rios is transported
back in time to 2024 alongside picard
rafi jaradi and seven of nine rios falls
in love with a 21st century woman named
teresa a doctor and mother running a
clinic in los angeles in the 25th
century gainan confirms that rios lived
out his life there starting a medical
supply company but is this really the
end of ryo's story if star trek has
taught us anything surprise returns are
the order of the day we know that la
sirena is equipped with a series of
holograms that uses ryosa's image so
it's not impossible that he could return
somewhere down the line as one of his
holographic assistants rios proved a
popular character with fans so there's a
good chance we haven't seen the last of
him yet
introduced in season 4 of star trek
voyager 7 of 9 has been on a journey
from being a villainous robotic drone
reliant on the borghive mind to becoming
a strong independent person who has
reclaimed her humanity in many small
steps
uh is something wrong
i am unaccustomed to this
borg do not sit
she expressed interest in joining
starfleet when the voyager crew returned
to the alpha quadrant wanting to follow
in captain janeway's footsteps in the
second season of picard we learned that
her dreams of federation service had
remained just that as starfleet rejected
her application thanks to her borg past
though fellow former drone up was
accepted spending her entire adult life
as a borg made starfleet wary of seven
in the finale of picard season two when
seven and the rest of picard's team
returned to the 25th century picard
gives her a field commission reasoning
that seven has the most experience with
the borg and is best suited to lead the
rest of the mission picard gives her the
captain's chair with the gerardi queen
and her unique borg collective now
requesting federation membership
combined with her field commission could
starfleet reconsider seven's application
actor jerry ryan has already made it
clear that she will appear in the series
third season and it's entirely possible
she could be a starfleet officer or a
borg ambassador when we see her next
during the next generation the
relationship between gainen and picard
was something of a mystery some of it
was resolved in the two-part episode
time's arrow in which picard traveled
back to 19th century earth and met
gainen from her perspective it was their
first meeting but all that changed in
picard leaving from an altered timeline
picard meets gainan in 2024 and for her
their encounter in the 1890s never
happened because the future picard left
from in times arrow no longer existed it
seemed that now their first meeting
occurred in 2024 i'll see you in 500
years but god and i'll see you
in a few minutes but with their mission
complete and the timeline from times
arrow now restored it would seem they've
met twice in the past in 1893 and again
in 2024. however in that version of 2024
she said she'd never met him so how
exactly does gainan's memory of picard
work are we now in a timeline where they
never met in the 19th century or is this
another case of infinite fragmented
timelines we're living through maybe
this is one question we shouldn't be
asking picard season 2 took the show's
crew on a mission to restore a timeline
fractured by q an important event in the
past had been changed and all of time
altered as a result we learned that it
centered on picard's ancestor renee an
astronaut who led a mission to europa in
2024 where she discovered a unique
organism without her missions success
all of time was rewritten and the future
twisted into a dark reality where
non-humans were subjugated by the
confederation and picard himself waged a
violent war of oppression but with this
organism new technologies would
apparently be developed that would
reverse all of the environmental damage
on earth the failure of the europa
mission meant the continued decimation
of the environment but it's not made
clear how that would have led to a
totalitarian world government in the
25th century nor does it explain why
adam sung would be known as an
anti-alien tyrant
the same galaxy
is a human galaxy
however in adam sung's timeline of 2024
first official contact with intelligent
alien life is still at least 40 years
away how did his conversations about the
future with jaradi and q lead him to
take such an aggressive anti-alien
stance and why was it embraced before
humanity had met any aliens at all
picard season 2 saw the borg queen
manipulating dr agnes gerardi and the
queen's motives were anything but noble
trapped in the 21st century and
imprisoned in one mind agnes and the
queen slowly merged into a single
sinister new hybrid would agnes become
the first borg queen and birth the
cyborg race in 2024 would she end up
creating the borg in the 21st century as
seven of nine feared not quite at the
urging of doradi the borg queen slowly
comes around and the two create a merged
personality with a new goal to save
wayward dying souls and resurrect them
as a new kind of borg collective with
our minds joined as one
we could be more
the newborg would be built on
cooperation and salvation not
assimilation in 2024 the gerardi queen
takes la sirena and leaves for parts
unknown the next time we see her in the
25th century she has a new massive
starship and is asking admiral picard
about joining the united federation of
planets that's all great but the
question remains what was the jaradi
queen doing for the past 400 years are
all of the borg terrors of the past
retconned into a separate timeline now
was she hiding in a distant part of the
galaxy to avoid disrupting the timeline
did she build a collective elsewhere did
she take part in galactic affairs we've
never seen there's now a 400 year gap
that needs a little explaining perhaps
the biggest unanswered question of the
bunch closes out the finale after the
combined efforts of the new borg and the
federation fleet prevent a disaster a
unique anomaly is created in the form of
a trans warp conduit seven of nine
recognizes it right away and notes that
it's unlike any she has seen before and
that's notable given her lengthy
experience with borg transwarp conduits
picard wonders who created the conduit
implying that this was not a natural
phenomenon its creation confounds even
the new borg queen but she knows that
it's a threat it's an ominous closing
message but if there's one question
likely to be resolved in season 3 it's
this one and it looks like picard will
need the help of his former enterprise
crew if he's going to discover the
answer the entire cast of the next
generation is joining the final season
of picard
[Music]